vous vous enfermez chez votre voisin
vous avez votre fille dans les bras et
secours arrive que se passe-t-il et
secours
arrive enfin avant ça il y a eu des
trucs mais enfin je suis pas arrivé à
faire le massage cardiaque c'est Nico
qui l'a fait c'était très compliqué et
tout votre voisin mon voisin ouais et du
coup les secours arrivent il y a le SAMU
mais à ce moment-là je reprends espoir
je me dis il faut qu'il la saauve et
tout et quand il branche le le
monitoring ou le et là je reprends
espoir et tout parce que j'ai j'ai
l'impression qu' a son cœur qui bat et
malgré les doutes et la vision d'horreur
et tout je me dis [__] elle viit
encore et tout faut qu'il la sauve quoi
et et malgré tout ça euh voilà un moment
il s'arrête et et il m'annonce que c'est
terminé
quoi votre maison est placée ensuite
sous cé vous vous retrouvez à l'hôpital
nu c'est ça euh je ouais donc à la suite
à la suite du du décès moi je suis
emmené je suis emmené dans les camions
de pompiers je suis à l'hôpital les
gendarmes arme j'étais en calçon et en
T-shirt je me levais il récupère mon
t-shirt mon calçon il le mettent dans
des pièces à conviction donc je me
retrouve nu en tenue en chambre
d'hôpital quoi en tunique d'hôpital et
euh et par la suite donc j'ai j'ai
j'avais plus de téléphone euh plus de
portefeuille plus de voiture plus de
maison je me suis retrouvé euh au sens
propre à poil alors ensuite euh votre
votre ex-compagne Sandra a avoué son
meurtre
h à 6h45 elle avait écré un SMS à sa
mère elle lui avait dit J'ai tué ma
fille il a voulu la garde totale je ne
peux vivre sans elle
euh comment elle avoué son meurtre à
part par ce ce sms elle a elle av fait
ce SMS dans un premier temps ensuite
quand je suis arrivé dans la chambre la
phrase qu'elle m'a dit tu as voulu nous
séparer c'est toi qui a fait ça tu as
voulu nous séparer les pompiers et les
gendarmes sont
arrivés sa déclaration c'étit de dire
euh j'ai réfléchi toute la nuit euh il
voulait me l'enlever j'étais obligé de
le
faire est-ce qu'elle lui avait déjà levé
la main dessus ça a toujours été une
femme douce sensible attentionnée il y a
aucun signe euh
elle l'a jamais frappé elle a jamais eu
un mot difficile pour elle elle était
très attentionnée et elle laissait
personne s'en occuper à part elle parce
qu'elle voulait que tout soit bien fait
tout bien cadré quoi il y avait que sa
mère moi-même j'ai été exclu au fil du
temps il y avit plus que sa mère qui
avait le droit de s'en occuper quoi
alors maintenant on va passer au encore
un
step puisque le le 9 novembre dernier le
procès a eu lieu votre enseigne votre
ancienne compagne a été déclarée
irresponsable pénalement elle sera donc
pas jugée et n'ira pas en
prison quand une irresponsabilité est
prononcée c'est qu'il y a eu au
préalable une contreexertise avec deux
autres experts euh et donc elle a été
considérée comme entre guillemets folle
donc pas de
procès après avoir mis 354 coups de
ciseau à votre fille à sa fille et
aujourd'hui donc pas de procès comment
vous avez accueilli cette cette décision
j'avais toujours gardé espoir que la
justice fasse son travail de parler les
expertises psychiatriqu et tout c'est
pour ça que moi j'ai jamais voulu
médiatiser cette histoire mais quand
quand il a été établi qu'elle allait
être irresponsable je suis dit je peux
pas accepter ça et je suis obligé de
dénoncer cette injustice et euh et j'ai
j'ai accueilli jusque à la chambre
d'instruction il y a eu la chambre
d'instruction j'ai toujours gardé espoir
j'ai eu le sentiment que le jury et
l'avocat général avait une lecture
objective parce qu'ils ont approuvé
qu'elle mentait sur ses voix ils ont
approuvé qu'elle avait une mémoire
parcellaire pour s'arranger et se
déculpabiliser euh elle met tout elle
rejette toute la culpabilité euh sur
moi-même et et du coup jusque à la
chambre d'instruction j'ai toujours
gardé espoir je me suis dit ils vont
prendre la la bonne décision et c'est le
16 novembre qu'ils ont annoncé qu'elle
était irresponsable et et j jusqu'à ce
jour-là je gardais espoir mais quand ils
ont annoncé ça j'ai été révolté B c'est
normal je ve dire vis-à-vis de ma fille
c'est c'est inaudible et c'est un manque
de respect incroyable aujourd'hui 3
semaines après le procès et et 3 ans
après le drame votre excomagne est à
l'hôpital euh elle y sera combien de
temps selon vous aucune idée voilà elle
est plus entre les mains de la justice
moi-même je sais pas où elle est
aujourd'hui euh placé dans quel hôpital
je ne sais pas je sais pas on me tiendra
pas informé de quand est-ce qu'elle
sortira elle sortira quand les experts
psychiatres jugeront qu'elle est lucide
et non dangereuse pour la société elle
peut sortir dans 2 ans comme dans 3 ans
5 ans bien sûr elle va sortir hein elle
va sortir oui elle va sortir
les c'est je vous dis moi c'est je suis
révolté par votre histoire aujourd'hui
et ce qu'on envie de savoir les les
téléspectateurs c'est comment Benjamin
on reprend une vie normale après un un
un tel drame là je crois que c'est le
pire la pire chose qui puisse arriver
euh c'est déjà la justice est très lente
très longue et jusqu'à cette procédure
je voilà mon combat c'était de rendre
justice à ma fille aujourd'hui c'est
terminé je me sens un peu désarmé mais
désappointé j'ai j'ai l'impression de
devir redémarrer à zéro maintenant je je
je réamorce travailler ou pas non je
travaille toujours pas ouais vous
arrivez pas je j'arrive pas à travailler
je me suis aussi fracturé la jambe ça a
été très long on m'a opéré il y a 4 mois
vous arrivez à vivre une vie normale
impossible
euh une vie
normale pour l'instant non parce que
j'arrive pas à reprendre le travail
c'est trop compliqué je suis tout toute
cette histoire tout tout ce tout ce
bruit que ça fait ça ça me ça m'épuise
quoi vous réhabitez dans votre maison ou
pas ouais j'habite dans ma maison la
maison où il y a eu le drame la maison
où il y a eu le drame ouais h ouais j'ai
pu réintégrer ma maison à la suite des
cambriolages de l'inondation il y a eu 8
mois de travaux qui ont été effectués
j'ai fait des combats contre les
assurances euh qui m'ont exclu mon
assurance habitation m'a exclu parce
queils m'ont expliqué qu'il y avait trop
de de sinistres sur ma maison donc j'ai
fait des combats avec les avocats euh et
une fois qu'elle a été rénovée
euh j'ai pu réintégrer ma maison ça
aussi on peut je voulais le le pointer
du doigt c'est c'est qu'on m'a rendu la
maison en l'état on est retourné avec
les gendarmes euh j'y suis allé avec un
uisser les gendarmes m' rendu les clés
devant ma porte d'entrée et et ils sont
partis et j'ai récupéré une maison
cambriolée gaziel extincteur inondé avec
la scène de crime c'est mon frère et mon
cousin qui ont nettoyé la scène de crime
et c'est moi-même euh dans un deuxième
enfin plus tard qui repeint le mur de la
chambre de ma fille parce que
je je ça me tenait à cœur de le faire
c'est c'est une manière de me
reconstruire donc j'ai réintégré cette
maison parce que pour moi c'est la
maison où ma fille a grandi où on a
partager tous ces moments de bonheur
c'est c'est mon pilier
psychologique j'ai mes nuits sont très
compliquées je dors très mal mais ça me
tient à cœur d'être là-bas à partir du
moment de toute façon où je suis seul
que je dorme chez moi ou ailleurs je mes
nuits c'est un cauchemar merci d'avoir
été avec nous et on pense on se dit on
se met tous à votre place on se dit que
c'est un véritable em merci en tout cas
pour votre témoignage très très fort et
on est on espère que vous allez pouvoir
vivre une vie normale mais même si on se
doute bien que c'est extrêmement
compliqué après ce que vous avez vécu en
tout cas merci avec nous allez-y je peux
ajouter que je je suis euh voilà je on a
une pétition je voulais aussi remercier
Christian stavowski et l'association
Delphine Cendrine formidable euh pour
essayer de faire avancer les choses sur
Modifier la loi de l'article 1221 c'est
ça donc je comptais sur vous Cyril pour
essayer de de N pti de ouais de faire
monter la pétition une pétition sens ah
je pensais que c terminé on va en parler
on va en parler demain non on va en
parler demain si on va parler tous les
jours pour faire monter cette pétition
parce que je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous puisque n'est pas finalement
responsable la personne qui a été qui
était atteinte au moment des faits d'un
trouble psychique ou neuropsychique
ayant aboli son discernement ù le
contrôle de ses actes et ça il a raison
ça il faut que ça bouge parce que c'est
inadmissible donc on va faire on en
parlera tous les jours pendant un petit
peu de temps merci bah merci à vous
merci beaucoup merci à tous
merci